bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui une voix forte dans la vie
politique bourguignonne une voie qui
peut nous parler d'à peu près tout andré
billardon a tout fait de conseiller
général à ministre-président de son
département de la région décuplée et
jusqu'à la fin du mois dernier maire du
creusot pendant plus de 20 ans bonjour
andré billardon bonjour on est très
content que vous soyez venu aujourd'hui
sur le plateau de la voie est libre on
va revenir avec vous sur ce parcours qui
couvre un vaste chapitre de la vie
politique française
vous allez bien sûr nous parler de cette
ville très particulière qu'elle creusot
mais d'abord allez une petite question
le nombre d'élections auxquelles vous
vous êtes présenté environ 20 sur toute
votre carrière et la première vous vous
en souvenez oui c'est une élection
municipale partielle en 1973 à autun ça
s'est fini comment j'ai gagné ma
première première d'une longue série de
victoires mais il ya eu quelques
défaites aussi on va en parler on va
actionner d'abord la machine à remonter
le temps
andré billardon vous entrer à
l'assemblée nationale en 1978
regardez c'est du noir et blanc seing
extrait d'un reportage intitulé portrait
du nouveau député du creusot alors mais
c'est bien dans comme un deuxième temps
député-es part au castillan est un désir
de puissance des responsabilités par
hasard ou pour aider les autres je crois
que ça mais ni une vocation ligne de
désir de puissance est certainement un
désir de servir les autres et c'est
certainement la vocation première
ces députés socialistes alors à
l'assemblée nationale il y à un ceux qui
dorment
il ya ceux qui partent renfort qui a les
ordres de quel côté de vous situez vous
situerez c'est difficile à dire parce
que je crois que pour l'instant je
savoure au stade de l'organisation
j'ai commencé à mettre en place un
programme c'est à dire que je partirai
de la circonscription le mardi matin
je resterai pendant la durée de la
session à paris jusqu'au jeudi soir ou
vendredi
donc j'ai l'intention de d'un député qui
effectivement siégera à l'assemblée qui
sera le porte parole des habitants des
travailleurs de la circonscription et
certainement pas un député qui dormira
l'assemblée alors je ris billardon ça
vous évoque
c'est un autre monde où ce pour vous
c'est très présent c'est presque hier
bon le temps le temps a fait son oeuvre
est d'abord sur moi même physiquement
j'entends mais et j'ai des souvenirs
d'ailleurs j'ai à mes côtés sur l'image
qui vient d'être présenté celui qui a
été longtemps mon suppléant qui était en
même temps premier adjoint au maire du
creusot de l'époque bernard loiseau qui
était une grande figure du creusot
également et là j'ai gentiment de
comment dire d'émotion à cet instant on
l'a on la sent en vous entendant vous
employer un mot vous dites des
travailleurs c'est un mot qu'on entend
plus vraiment dans la bouche d'un député
socialiste au soir son élection
maintenant peut-être mais moi je le
regretterai volontiers le mot de
travailleurs est un bon mot et que
j'emploie encore et pour prolonger la
question des adjectifs
quand on disait de moi maintenant je
parle pas c'est maintenant que j'étais
le maire socialiste du creusot je
considère que c'est être quelque chose
de bien
pas seulement le maire mais aussi le
maire socialiste du creusot entre un
député de 1978 et un député de 2015
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux les
chaînes d'info continue
est ce que les choses sont différentes
escales débat politique et plus
transparents ou est ce que finalement il
est supprimée par cette transparence
je trouve que ce qui est permanent ce
sont les valeurs mais j'ai parfois le
sentiment que tout le reste a changé et
qu'en particulier pas au bénéfice du
fonds car les réseaux sociaux les
chaînes permanente continue donne 2
comment dire de la légèreté de
l'immédiateté
et au détriment du fond de la réflexion
moi je suis de ceux qui le regrette mais
je suis maintenant un vieil homme à la
retraite et par conséquent je suis pas
le meilleur juge mais quand même je
pense que la politique n'y a pas
toujours gagner vous avez été président
de groupe à l'assemblée vous allaitez
vice président de l'assemblée des
bagarres à l'intérieur d'une majorité il
y en a eu bien sûr beaucoup supposent
mais on n'entendait pas forcément parler
de la même manière on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui tout va se passer
finalement ce aux quatre colonnes devant
les devant les caméras plus que dans les
salles c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai ou
c'est c'est une fausse impression
ils iraient beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins de bagarres ah d'accord
draguer un souvenir j'ai un souvenir en
la décision est prise de passer à la
proportionnelle pour élire les députés
qui avaient comme conséquence alors
qu'on était très dominant je pense au
département de saône et loire comme au
département de la nièvre où on
sacrifiait délibérément des députés qui
étaient en place et qui ne serait pas
réélu du fait de la proportionnelle il
n'a pas manqué à l'époque et je m'en
souviens bien puisque j'étais président
du groupe n'a pas manqué une voix pour
voter un tel texte il a fallu du temps
pour convaincre tout le monde
il n'y a pas vraiment de bagarre il y
avait sans doute beaucoup plus
qu'aujourd'hui
une discipline ce qui manque me
semble-t-il dans la vie politique
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'aspect plus
collectif et là on y perd beaucoup me
semble-t-il
alors vous devez des ministres de
secrétaires d'état à l'énergie je crois
mini ce ministre à l'énergie
les mots ont un sens dans le
gouvernement de pierre bérégovoy pendant
sept mois 92 93 regardez c'est votre
premier déplacement de ministre si
l'explosion de la raffinerie de la mède
dans les bouches du rhône fin octobre
fut le premier contact d'andré billardon
avec une raffinerie
la visite d'aujourd'hui à donges lui
aura permis de découvrir une raffinerie
en fonctionnement la plus importante de
france c'était la première étape d'une
journée dans l'ouest pour le tout
nouveau ministre délégué à l'énergie qui
entend avec un programme d'action précis
apporter sa contribution à la politique
énergétique de la france
je crois qu'il est utile de relancer en
particulier la maîtrise de l'énergie
car celle ci fait toujours pas partie de
la politique énergétique mais souffre je
crois d'un peu de d'abandon donc c'est
une des mes priorités andré billardon
souvenirs je vous regarde et pendant les
images c'est fort encore se souvenir
oui parce que moi je suis peut-être le
seul à ne pas avoir oublié qu'à l'époque
j'ai fait voter au parlement une loi qui
sécurisaient l'approvisionnement en
pétrole et on était dans une période un
peu trouble et le golf était agité qui
ont pu détourner les choses ainsi et ce
texte est un texte important mais je
suis sans doute le seul à me souvenir
que c'est moi qui les fait voter au
parlement
on se souvient en tout cas on retrouve
ça dans les textes que vous avez aussi
travaillé sur un texte concernant les
lignes à haute tension préfigure ce qui
est aujourd'hui le débat public lorsqu à
de grands projets d'infrastructures on a
envie de laisser sa marque quand on est
ministre
oui une circulaire qui à l'époque a été
fait pour une ligne à l'occasion du
tracé d'une ligne transpyrénéenne
c'était très compliqué parce qu'une
partie des des terrains côté espagnol
était propriété du roi à vous imaginez
bien que les discussions étaient un peu
compliqués je pense que la notion de
débat public trouve sinon ces racines là
à cette occasion du moins cette occasion
a permis d'enrichir ce qui est
aujourd'hui une pratique constante
extrêmement utile dans une démocratie
moderne
on en parle beaucoup il ya de grands
projets effectivement c'est une période
très particulière quand même ces années
90 est ce que c'est la fin de quelque
chose il ya des scandales il ya d'un art
tapis à ce moment là il y aura le
suicide de pierre bérégovoy vous avez
vécu ça de très près on a dit que
c'était une perte de repères pour le
pour le les socialistes la fin de
quelque chose la fin de l'époque de
françois mitterrand
c'est toujours lorsqu'il arrive une
situation de ce type là où vous vous
êtres chers
moi je le souvenir de la campagne les
élections législatives 93 où j'étais au
gouvernement
c'était absolument terrible c'est un
véritable calvaire que de faire campagne
à cette époque j'ai d'ailleurs été battu
je note au passage que c'est la seule
fois mais j'ai été battu et donc c'est
forcément la fin de quelque chose
vous avez évoqué bernard tapie j'ai
siégé au gouvernement avec lui je
regarde pas qu'un meilleur souvenir
par contre je garde avec émotion le
souvenir de pierre bérégovoy la question
déjà grand bonhomme
comment vous avez on est encore dans
l'émotion mais le suicide de pierre
bérégovoy c'est quelque chose qui a
marqué beaucoup de gens parti socialisme
dans la classe politique médiatique
aussi d'ailleurs ce qu'on se souvient
des accusations de françois mitterrand
on sait d'ailleurs depuis qu'il sanglots
bay dans ces accusations mais qu'il ne
l'avait pas dit publiquement comment
vous avez réagi à ce moment là andré
billardon mois le suicide de pierre
bérégovoy m'a attiré c'était un homme
solide
il fallait qu'il soit solide compte tenu
de ses origines pour devenir le premier
ministre de la france
il n'avait pas été programmé par ses
études par exemple pour qu'il en soit
ainsi les aux plus jeunes qui avait
commencé comme ouvrier il absolument à
la base
absolument et donc nous sommes sortis
totalement atterré de cet événement
tragique et les déclarations les
accusations de françois mitterrand on
raisonnait pendant très longtemps à nos
oreilles
les rapports entre la politique et les
médias ont été depuis ce jour là je
crois durement marqué et il en reste
encore aujourd'hui sans doute quelque
chose d'ailleurs c'est tellement vrai
que dans un de temps à autre vous même
vos confrères naturellement revienne sur
cet aspect alors il ya
mauvaise image des médias il faut le
dire il ya aussi une mauvaise image des
politiques aujourd'hui
vous parliez tout à l'heure de ce moment
93 avec un rejet très fort d'une partie
des électeurs qui avaient massivement
voté pour la gauche en 1981 il y a eu
des alternances au fil de ces décennies
on en est arrivé à un point où
aujourd'hui on sait on en parle beaucoup
de rejet d'une partie de la classe
politique comment est ce que vous vivez
ça quelle analyse vous en avez vous qui
fait partie de la génération qui a voulu
changer d'avis en 1981
je crois qu'il faut que l'on règle un
problème puisque vous évoquez 80 mon
parti à l'époque était imparti de
conquête du pouvoir
il en avait été écarté pendant des
décennies et donc nous étions là avec un
projet de rupture avec la société en
place c'est sur ce projet de rupture que
françois mitterrand devenu président de
la république
et puis deux puis se sont succédé les
alternances la gauche la droite dans un
système institutionnel de la vème
république
bien bien campé sur ses positions de ce
fait les gens me semble-t-il parfois à
tort ont le sentiment que les
alternances ne servent pas à grand chose
que la droite et la gauche font un peu
la même chose et qu'il ne réussisse pas
pour ne pas dire qu'ils échouent sur un
certain nombre de dossiers
résultat tout ça ils le cherchent
ailleurs pourquoi tout simplement parce
que si la gauche et la droite font un
peu la même chose sur certains dossiers
ne reste pas moins qu'à l'occasion de la
première élection bien le combat est
violent et donc les gens n'y comprennent
plus ne s'y retrouve plus et dans ces
conditions ils vont chercher ailleurs
hélas hélas tenté par certes pour
certains par le populisme
une voix qui est une voie sans issue
mais qui est une voie aujourd'hui que
certains jeunes
hélas on envie d'emprunter est ce qu'il
ya aussi une dimension d'image
d'honnêteté l'impression qu'on donne est
ce que vous êtes attaché à ça on
reproche aux politiques de
pas toujours appliqués dans leur vie
quotidienne dans leur comportement on a
eu des exemples en saône et loire avec
thomas thévenoud par exemple d'appliquer
ce qu'ils demandent ce qu'ils demandent
à leurs électeurs
est ce que pour vous ça a été une ligne
directrice votre image ce que vous étiez
ce que vous faisiez j'ai presque envie
de vous renvoyer la question vous parlez
vous parler à juste titre d'ailleurs de
ce qui ne va pas quand parlez vous de ce
qui a fonctionné de ce qui fonctionne
c'est à dire du fait que l'immense
majorité des politiques sont des gens
honnêtes qui ne s'enrichissent pas qui
parfois gagnent moins d'argent en
faisant de la politique que dans le
métier qu'ils occupaient précédemment
pourquoi tout simplement parce que aussi
on est dans une société très médiatique
je n'accuse pas les médias parce que les
politiques anjou des médias mais on dîne
dans une société où tout va si vite
aujourd'hui on n'a pas le temps qu'on
n'a plus le temps d'aller au fond des
choses
est-ce que vous qui avez été numéro 2 du
parti socialiste vous connaissez votre
parti parker sur le bout des doigts
il a encore de l'avenir le parti
socialiste parce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure vous avez dit c'était un parti
qui était fait pour accéder au pouvoir
prendre le pouvoir a créé par françois
mitterrand pour ça mais il sert plus à
rien maintenant j'ai la vie tout à fait
inverse
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas la première fois
qu'on se pose cette question
on s'est posé y compris après 93 à
chaque fois qu'on s'est posé la question
de savoir si le parti socialiste avait
encore un avenir
les faits ont apporté la toujours la
même réponse
le parti socialiste il est toujours là
et ses valeurs il doit se refonder sans
aucun doute à certaines époques sans
doute aussi changer les hommes
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je m'en
vais une certaine manière
rajeunir les troupes pour autant le
parti socialiste et l'âge je ne doute
pas un instant qu'il est un avenir à
condition qu'ils savent évidemment
s'adapter aux temps à l'époque et aux
événements dans un monde qui change si
vite
est ce que les procès sont plus grand
aujourd'hui entre l'ailé gauche du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
les frondeurs et puis les gens qui
suivent la ligne du gouvernement qui est
extrêmement pragmatique certains parlent
même de social libéral aujourd'hui est
ce qu'on n'est pas dans un
fossé entre les deux beaucoup plus grand
que tout ce qui a jamais eu à
l'intérieur du parti où c'était plus
souvent des écuries de personnes pas
seulement
pas seulement pourquoi pourquoi
voudrait-on qu il n'y ait pas diversité
fussent une diversité extrêmement large
j'ai été comme vous l'avez rappelé à un
moment donné aux en responsabilité au
sein de mon parti
j'ai toujours considéré que l'expression
on appelle des courants plus que les
écuries des courants c'est quelque chose
qui est riche
d'ailleurs on a plutôt tendance à nous
imiter quand je vois l'évolution des
partis de droite
on est plutôt aussi sur quelque chose
qui va un peu dans cette direction donc
je crois moi un parti qui soit dit vais
vous faire une confidence
lorsque j'étais numéro 2 de pierre
mauroy
j'avais rêvé de congrès de tours à
l'envers c'est à dire d'une
réunification avec le parti communiste
façon d'avoir un seul grand parti de la
gauche extrêmement divers je dois dire
que je n'ai pas eu un très grand succès
y compris à l'internet
alors on va parler du creusot bien sûr
ton histoire son identité un mot d'abord
de la région parce que vous étiez le
lundi de l'élection marie-guite dufay
dans les tribunes et puis vous l'avez
présider la région vous avez dit à les
connecter tout à l'heure quand on peut
préparer cette émission pas longtemps du
tout c'est vrai mais tout de même vous
faites partie de ceux qui croient qu'ils
ont cru à cette idée de la
décentralisation que beaucoup de choses
devaient se faire un échelon qui
n'étaient pas les champs de l'état ah je
suis un décentralisation forcené et je
me souviens vraiment très bien des
relations des discussions à l'époque
avec gaston defferre qui est celui qui
avait porté au début des années 80 le
grand projet de décentralisation
je trouve même qu'on n'est pas assez
loin aujourd'hui et il en reste beaucoup
à faire
cependant l'exemple des régions y
compris des grandes régions les moyens
financiers de la bourgogne franche comté
n'ont rien à voir avec des moyens
financiers du plus petit des landes
d'allemagne donc il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin
pourquoi parce que ça libère des
énergies ça permet à l'imagination de
terrain de
c'est à gauche qu'on entend souvent une
opposition à cette décentralisation sur
la rupture de l'égalité entre les
territoires
c'est quelque chose qu'on entend souvent
en disant si certaines régions mettre
plus d'argent sur les lycées bas il y
aura une rupture d'égalité par exemple
et ça c'est la gauche qui le dit souvent
oui parce qu'il en a encore à gauche des
des relents d'étatisme ça vous
surprendrai naturellement si si je vous
disais l'un vertes
mais est il là de culture au sein de de
la gauche il ya une culture plus
étatiste et une culture plus
décentralisatrice je pense que le sens
de l'histoire c'est que la seconde
l'emportent sur la première est le sens
de l'histoire c'était d'agrandir la
taille des régions vue du creusot on en
pense quoi
ah oui alors totalement parce que
précisément les régions sont trop
faibles leurs données c'était très
important pour la bourgogne qui était
une petite région démographiquement
parlant lui donner plus de taille plus
plus d'habitants en d'autres termes
étaient quelque chose me semble-t-il
d'important gg à l'époque trouvé que
c'était peut-être insuffisant de réunir
la bourgogne la franche comté mais les
choses sont faites aujourd'hui est folle
et il faut aller de l'avant
vous avez dit décentralisateur forcené
on pourrait dire intercommunale je sais
pas comment il faudrait dire parce que
le creusot s'est engagé très tôt et dans
l'échelle de l'intercommunalité c'était
dans les années 70 c'était une
originalité la communauté urbaine
creusot montceau
à part les grandes villes c'était la
première communauté urbaine qui
regroupait on va dire des villes qui
n'était conforme est pas une très grande
agglomération
avec du recul est-ce que c'était une
bonne idée
d'abord pourquoi l'avoir fait dans les
premiers comme ça alors que ce n'était
pas forcément l'esprit du texte au
départ et puis avec du recul est-ce que
c'était une bonne idée
figurez vous que l'histoire nous indique
que la l'europe naissante dès 1960 à
réfléchir
regardez ce qui se passait en saône et
loire pourquoi parce que la saône et
loire
il y avait du charbon de lassus au
creusot et à montceau et qu'un rapport
était sorti dans ces années du début des
années 60 de proposer qui consistait à
proposer que chalon le creusot et
montceau fassent cause commune
avant même la législation sur les
communautés urbaines
la suite a montré qu' il n'a pas été
possible de faire à trois le regrette et
et c'est une question qui
se reposera inévitablement dans les
années qui viennent on n'a pas pu faire
à trois on l'a fait à deux
bon sang que c'est difficile mais
combien c'est utile et les résultats
sont là
je crois seulement un exemple le
développement universitaire qui fait que
le creusot à la deuxième ville
universitaire évidemment après dijon de
bourgogne il fallait le faire et la
communauté urbaine l'a fait je pourrais
citer une multitude d'exemples y compris
la réindustrialisation du creusot c'est
bien sûr la force de la communauté qui
l'a permis
mais c'est difficile de s'entendre dans
une collectivité qui n'est pas une vraie
agglomération qui est bipolaire et où
les histoires les cultures entre le
creusot et montceau sont si différentes
que pour arriver à avancer ce qu'on veut
n'arrive à faire il faut beaucoup
d'efforts beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup
de bonne volonté passe pour expliquer la
plupart des communes urbaines c'est une
grande ville centre et puis toute la
couronne autour plus ou moins vastes
sont des tableaux voilà et vous la
difficulté c'était ces deux villes
vous venez de prononcer le mot
réindustrialisation on va y venir bien
sûr parce que je le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez été député du creusot
vous avez été président de la communauté
urbaine mer pendant plus de 20 ans
d'abord comment vous vous définiriez
cette ville qui est quand même une ville
à part pour ceux qui n'y sont jamais
allés on traverse la campagne il ya des
prêts il ya des vaches
et puis on arrive dans un lieu un peu
particulier avec une ville autour d'une
usine on peut le dire comme ça
ah oui c'est quoi cette ville mais c'est
une ville entreprises c'est une ville
qui s'est créé et développé organisée
autour de son site industriel en fait
d'un groupement du sinn de la même
entreprise
c'est la ville
longtemps la ville schneider est donc
tout est structuré toute son histoire
est structuré et tout ce qui compose une
ville a été structurée par précisément
cette notion de vie l'entreprise et il
en reste encore beaucoup de traces dans
le domaine économique surtout dans le
domaine urbain c'est à dire dans
l'organisation de la ville où le site
industriel qui
fait 250 ha si on va jusqu à montchanin
qui s'étend sur près de sept kilomètres
ce site industriel couple agglomérations
en deux comme un fleuve partagent une
agglomération en deux c'est toute une
histoire qui finalement s'est écrite à 7
et ça veut dire que la vie la culture de
la ville l'histoire de la ville elle se
superpose à l'histoire économique et
sociale aussi avec les luttes sociales
les deux choses sur perpos intimement
tout a procédé de la ville les luttes
par définition mais également
l'organisation urbaine la ville n'était
pas une ville au sens traditionnel du
terme
c'était une ville addition de quartier
qui se répartissaient de paris de part
et d'autre du site industriel
souvent d'ailleurs six quartiers étaient
des quartiers qui correspondait au fait
qu'on était ouvrier qu'on était
contremaître ou qu'on était ingénieur
donc elle est totalement atypique mais
ça était vrai delà de l'enseignement les
écoles schneider ont été à un moment
donnée très importante au creusot les
églises étaient les églises de ce nerf
l'hôpital et un hôpital de schneider
tout procédait de schneider et donc il
en reste aujourd'hui des traces qui
évidemment sont presque dans l'adn des
creusotins pour autant il a fallu la
moderniser parce que il faut à la fois
être fière de son héritage de son passé
on ne fait rien sans son passé mais en
même temps il faut des ruptures parce
que la modernité c'est aussi de la
rupture
alors vous le disiez vous parler de
rupture les plus jeunes ne se
souviennent pas qu'en 1984 lempire
creusot loire s'est effondré ce qui
voulait dire pour le creusot que la
totalité de son activité économique
mettait la clé sous la porte on peut le
dire comme ça c'était un séisme complète
à total total parce que cette cette
période a été l'occasion d'une triple
crise évidemment comme quand chaque
grand empire industriel qui s'effondre
qui est qui est dispersée au gré des
repreneurs au travers d'une liquidation
judiciaire
c'est très compliqué en soit
économiquement évidemment sur le plan
social c'est extrêmement douloureux
on en oublie
aujourd'hui bien sûr le fait que
certains sont partis entre en
préretraite à 47 ans et demi au creusot
en 84 87 et donc vous voyez le 6 mai il
faut ajouter une dimension qui est sans
doute la dimension dont on parle le
moins mais qui est peut-être la plus
essentielle au regard de l'histoire
c'est le fait que cette ville a perdu
son identité ville d'une entreprise et
l'entreprise est dispersée l'entreprise
est liquidée
qu'est ce que c'est que le creusot qui
n'a plus éléments sont éléments
fondateurs sont éléments historiques
tout sur toute son histoire et il
fallait avoir du courage de croix pour
reconstruire quelque chose après cela
alors justement on fait un saut dans le
temps aujourd'hui le trophée 22300 a dit
ange par quelque chose comme ça pas de
friches industrielles quasiment et la
plupart des activités historiques
reprise par des grands groupes
arcelor alstom areva general electric
safran
alors il s'est passé quoi parce que en
lorraine il ya des friches industrielles
à perte de vue
l'industrie française industries lourdes
quasiment morte pro creusot il ya
toujours de l'industrie quel rôle vous
avez joué là dedans alors il y a eu et
il y a eu les rituels et dire les reste
le mot ne convient sans doute pas il est
trop péjoratif mais les suites des
activités de creusot loire qui ont été
reprises en réalité pas essentiellement
trois repreneurs le lundi repreneur a
fait ce qu'est alstom aujourd'hui
l'autre repreneur était framatome avant
areva et le troisième était usinor et ça
au gré d'un plan départemental qui s'est
avérée à la fois courageux et utile mais
il s'est ajouté à cela de nouvelles
créations quand on évoque safran la
suite ma c'est une création poste
84 le développement du lot aujourd'hui
qui est un des leaders dans le domaine
du chariot élévateur
c'est un des leaders et donc c'est une
création postérieur elle avait fait quoi
vous avez pris votre bâton de pèlerin
pour aller voir ces grands groupes en
leur disant il faut remettre de l'argent
creusot
on n'avait rien à faire puisque
l'industrie française marchait pas à ce
moment là non on s'est dit d'abord il
faut faire comme tout le monde
en 85 on s'est dit c'est elle la
doctrine de l'époque qui a aujourd'hui
de boer est faut faire il faut
accueillir des pme et il faut faire du
développement économique de services
services à la personne en particulier
on l'a fait on n'a pas échappé à une
règle qui était celle de la pensée du
moment ça a donné des résultats et et
s'est passé une chose qui nous a conduit
à réfléchir à nouveau c'est le fait
qu'un certain nombre d'implantations de
la fin des années 80 ont connu des
difficultés du fait de retournement de
conjoncture du début des années 90 et on
s'est aperçu que ceux qui étaient là la
pensée du moment la stratégie qui était
développée au plan national
rappelez-vous les parcs à thème de la
lorraine ça ne suffisait pas au creusot
parce qu'en plus le creusot n'est pas
sur un axe de circulation
le creusot n'a pas une zone de
chalandise pour développer du commerce
contrairement à d'autres villes et par
conséquent qu'il fallait enrichir notre
propre réflexion et l'enrichissement à
considérer a constaté à à se dire après
tout si l'avenir n'est pas industriel ya
peut-être pas d'avenir pour le creusot
et donc il faut mettre le paquet sur la
question industrielle
ça c'est un raisonnement qui s'est
construit depuis 85
jusque dans les années 2000 au fil du
temps avec une volonté il n'a pas été
top départ on fait ça ça s'est fait au
fil du temps c'est au fil du temps que
la réflexion s'est enrichie et j'insiste
beaucoup sur l'aspect avec tout le monde
quatre cents sans cet apport historique
on n'aurait rien réussi vous pensez que
ça marcherait aussi bien ré
industrialisation du creusot quand 84
non impossible à penser non on n'avait
pas prévu la situation d'aujourd'hui est
aujourd'hui la situation sinon sinon
heureuse du moins il ya des atouts
hyacinthe industriels il ya des
entreprises qui sont dans la
mondialisation a un avenir
il ya un avenir partout sucre à coup sûr
un avenir l'art l'industrie a un avenir
y compris dans les pays développés j'ai
toujours cru d'ailleurs le modèle
américain l'a montré
merci en et billardon pour cette
première demi heure d'émission on va
parler aussi de votre action de mer la
population du vivre ensemble de toutes
les choses qui font la vie d'une commune
et que vous avez pu expérimenter pendant
plus de 20 ans en tant qu' en tant que
maire du creusot
mais on s'arrête quelques minutes le
temps désinformation da mi journée et de
la météo dans les informations il va
d'ailleurs être question de l'élection
hier soir du nouveau maire du creusot
qui vous a succédé on se retrouve juste
après a tout de suite